اعلن الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شن غارات
استهدفت مجمع لتصنيع مكونات الصواريخ تحت
الارض تابع لحركه حماس في مخيم المغازي
وسط قطاع غزه وقال المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان القصف جاء ردا على
اطلاق قضاء افاروقيه من غزه مساء امس
الخميس الخميس من جهتها قالت كتائب القسام
الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس ان القصف
الاسرائيلي استهدف موقع الكتيبه 13 على
مدخل مخيم البريج وسط قطاع غزه
واضافت كتائب القسام في اول تعقيب على
الغارات الاسرائيليه فرج اليوم انه
مضاداتها الارضيه تصدت للطائرات
الاسرائيليه
اما حركه وحبس فوصفات القصف الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه بانه عدوان سافر وامتداد
للحرب المفتوحه على الشعب الفلسطيني وقال
الناطق باسم الحركه حازم قاسم في بيان ان
ما سماه الارهاب الصهيوني لن يوقف ثوره
الشعب الفلسطيني المتصاعده من جانبها قالت
كتائب القسام الجناح العسكري للحركه ان
القصف الاسرائيلي استهدف موقعا لها وسط
قطاع غزه
معنا من قطاع غزه مراسل الجزيره والا
الدحدوح وائل ماذا عن الوضع في هذه
الساعات
الوضع عبد القادر في هذه الساعات هادئ
تماما لا يوجد اي غارات جديده منذ اكثر من
خمس ساعات اي بعد الغارات التي نفذتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه فجر اليوم
في وسط قطاع غزه وبالتالي لم نعد نستمع
ايضا حتى لاصوات الطائرات وهي تحلق كما
جرت العاده اصوات الطائرات الاسرائيليه
المسيره هي الاخرى تسمع بين الحين والاخر
في مناطق متفرقه وان كانت ليس بنفس
الوتيره التي كانت عليها خلال الغارات او
حتى قبل الغارات او حتى في الايام الماضيه
التي لم تنفذ فيها غارات اسرائيليه بكل
الاحوال الوضع عاد الى طبيعته الناس
بطبيعه الحال افاقه هذا اليوم على اصوات
الانفجارات الشديده همم نظرا لانفجار هذه
القنابل الكبيره التي القتها طائرات
الاسرائيليه اكثر من 10 قنابل او صواريخ
اطلقت باتجاه هذا الموقع الذي يتبع لكتائب
القسام على مدخل مخيم المغازي وسط قطاع
غزه الامر الذي خلف اضرارا جسيمه في
الموقع ومحيطه فضلا عن بعض الاضرار التي
طالت ايضا عددا من المنازل كتشيم النوافذ
وغيرها لكن لا لا يوجد اصابات في صفوف
المواطنين ولا حتى في صفوف المقاومين
الفلسطينيين باعتبار ان هذه المواقع عبد
القادر يتم اخلاها كل ما كانت ال- الاوضاع
متوتره كما حصل ليله امس وايضا هذه
المواقع هي بعيدا نسبيا ليست بعيده كثيرا
عن منازل المواطنين ولذلك عندما تستهدف
بهذه بهذا بهذه الشده بالتاكيد يخلف
اضرارا في منازل المواطنين لكن لم يبلغ عن
وقوع
هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه جاءت من نفس
المكان الذي اعلن جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
او استهدفت نفس المكان الذي اعلن جيش
الاحتلال بانه اطلقت من خلاله بعض القذائف
الصاروخيه باتجاه منطقه الغلاف لكنها لم
تصل او لم تخلف اضرارا في الجانب
الاسرائيلي ولا حتى اصابات كان متوقعا عبد
القادر بان يلجا جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الى تنفيذ ضربات محدوده ومركزه ضد مواقع
عسكريا هامشيه همم او او او مواقع معتبره
ايضا لكن ما جرى حتى هذه اللحظات يؤكد بان
جيش الاحتلال همم ملتزم بقواعد الاشتباك
التي ظلت صامده على مدار السنوات والاشهر
الماضيه من غزه شكرا